[Music]
hey guess what it's me again
and we're doing another book review now
here's one that i uh had
talked about on my tbr list as everybody
had read it but me and i'm finally
getting around to it this actually came
out in 2014
and this is a little book called the
troop
by nick cutter now nick cutter
is actually i didn't know this until
five minutes before
i started recording this review but uh
it's actually the
pen name or one of the pen names of a
writer named craig davidson who is
canadian
and under his real name he writes
literary fiction but he also has a
couple different pen names
um nick cutter being one of them i think
the other one is like patrick
letusca or something like that uh where
he writes kind of more horror
type of stuff um so this book right here
like i said this has been like all over
book review channels and stuff like that
so many people have recommended it it's
like it has massively high ratings on
goodreads it's like four and a half star
average
um and most of the reviews of it are
very good and look at this it even has
an
endorsement from mr stephen king himself
right there on the front saying the book
scared the hell out of him you know
so uh you know that that's going to be a
good recommendation
at all times so let's get into this a
little bit now
there will probably be uh pretty major
spoilers for this because like i said
it's very very hard to talk about
the book without spoiling some stuff so
if you uh haven't read the book and want
to read the book and don't watch it
spoiled for you then obviously you need
to kind of check out and then
go read it and then come back later on
but if you have already read it and just
want to talk about it or if you just
don't give a [ __ ]
then uh please continue so this book
which came out in 2014 i'm gonna
i'm gonna say right here this is this
was a very fun book it's also
very very gross if you are like
if you're a real seasoned horror person
like especially if you're kind of around
like real gory [ __ ] or real a lot of
body horror they probably won't bother
you too much
i'm kind of giving that warning mostly
for people who
are not all that seasoned with horror or
are more into like ghost story or
supernatural type [ __ ]
this is a very very gross graphic
body horror type of book um
specifically having to do with parasites
and there's also um quite a bit
of animal cruelty and it's pretty
uh vividly described and so if that
seems like this something's going to
bother you then
probably you don't want to read this um
because it does get pretty nasty
but it it bothered me but not i've read
a lot worse which i'm sure like a lot of
you know if you're really into horror
i'm sure you've read a lot worse too
but i'm just saying if you're not like a
big horror veteran or don't read a lot
of body horror gory stuff
um this might bother you because it's
actually pretty gross
so the premise of the book is that there
is a
little scout troupe in canada and it's
led by scoutmaster tim
and i guess every year he takes some of
his scouts
on like a little camping vacation i
think it's only like
over over a long weekend or something
like that i can't remember how long it
was supposed to be i think it was only
three days
so um they go out to this place called
fallstaff
island which is essentially just a
really small
deserted island and it's off the coast
of prince edward island
so you can't really get so even like on
the mainland there isn't like a whole
bunch of stuff so already you're getting
the sense of like isolation
so this particular weekend he takes five
boys
out on this yearly trip now these boys
are named max kent
newton shelley and ephraim or ephraim
i i keep wanting to say it looks like
ephraim i've seen that name before but
i'm not entirely sure how to pronounce
it
but then his friends call him if which i
thought
well maybe that means that it's a long e
and that i should be saying ephraim but
maybe i'm thinking about this too much i
don't really know
so each of these boys kind of has their
own thing
like you know you have kent who's sort
of like
not a bully necessarily but he's kind of
one of those golden boy
jock types who's kind of like always
picking on people but
kind of saying it's good natured i
suppose so it's that and he's good at
everything like he's good at all the
sports and athletics and whatnot
then you have newton who's kind of your
stereotypical kind of chubby
nerdy kid who knows everything is into a
lot like a lot of weird geeky stuff
then you have um ephraim or ephraim who
is
seems like a nice kid but he has uh
anger issues
so they go into that a little bit max
who is kind of like the all-around
loyal good friend type of kid and then
you have
shelly shelley is
a psychopath this is not revealed it's i
guess it's kind of revealed very very
slowly because
you kind of get some stuff of him
earlier where
he seems very interested in
taking things apart and being able to do
whatever he pleases and things like that
but it very very slowly ramps up
and i think that his the addition of his
character to this i mean it's like a
very it because this goes sort of in
its body horror and parasites and stuff
but then it goes like in
it has a little bit of a lord of the
flies type of [ __ ] going on too
because you have all these boys and they
don't have any adult supervision
so i think the addition of shelley's
character really kind of
made this story maybe a lot more layered
or a lot more interesting than
it might have been otherwise because not
only do you have this
frankly horrifying situation going on on
this island with this parasite which
i'll get into a little bit
but then you have this added horror
of this kid who is just a [ __ ]
straight-up psychopath and is so so
happy
that he's on abandoned on this island
there's no adults there's all this bad
[ __ ] happening and he's super into it
because he's like woo he can just
um indulge like his worst proclivities
and this kid
is or he's like straight up serial
killer [ __ ]
you know and he's like 14 years old i
think they're all about 14 or around
that age
but yeah so i think the addition to that
character was like a really good idea
now nick cutter said that um in the
there's kind of like a postscript where
he was talking about
you know you know thanks and everything
like that and he said that he got the
idea to
write this book in the format that it's
written in from stephen king's
carrie which i think was a really
interesting thing to do because
so what he do what he does is that most
of the narrative is kind of focused on
each of the boys and on scout master tim
like you know someone so each chapter
kind of goes
into their thought processes and what
they're thinking about and what they're
doing
so you get kind of like boots on the
ground sort of thing of the parasite
[ __ ] taking over
and it's all very uh claustrophobic and
isolating because like i said they're
all on this island all alone
and this terrible [ __ ] is happening but
then like to get a broader perspective
he brings in essentially the same thing
that they had in cary whereas like every
now and then there'll be
like a newspaper article or there will
be
um a transcript of uh testimony like
from some trial that happened like in
the future like after this incident
occurred
now i do like that they did that because
it's kind of like close percep
you know close perspective close
perspective and then like wider
perspective because otherwise
you know it's it's all just these few
characters on this one island and if it
was all from their point of view you
know you might not get like a wider
perspective on what is actually
happening and what's going on
but i will say one tiny tiny thing that
i can
criticize is that sometimes the articles
because they're peppered throughout the
narrative
they kind of foreshadow stuff to not
even foreshadow they basically
just tell you what's gonna happen
because very very early on in the story
um there's a article i can't even
remember but i remember this being
pretty early on in the book
where there's um a newspaper article and
it's basically talked about the falstaff
island incident which is what they're
calling it and
you know this uh article was from
sometime you know in the future
and it basically straight up tells you
that one person
survived you don't know who that person
is until the very end
but so the whole entire time you know
that everybody but one of these people
is gonna die you know what i mean i
don't know i don't i don't know if that
really because it's still like a really
really compelling and really
entertaining read
but i'm not sure if maybe it played
its hand too early i don't know i don't
know if i really want to say that but
i can kind of say that you know
sometimes you would read the articles
you would read the testimony
uh from the people later that were you
know trying to defend their actions
you know when this whole like [ __ ] storm
took place
and i don't know i feel like maybe some
of it i would have put it a little bit
later but like i said it's a very very
minor
criticism i'm not going to go too much
into it but you know i'm just that's
just something that
that occurred to me like while i was
reading it so you have these
five boys and their scout leader and
they're doing you know regular scout
[ __ ] as you would do
like on a couple day camping trip and i
guess they've been on them before
uh so this is not like new territory for
them and they all seem pretty savvy
um you know in the woods they can all
build fires they all have all their
stuff and everything
so very shortly into this trip i believe
it's the first night when they get there
they're on this uh you know they're in
their little cabin or whatever
and this boat comes up to the island
and there's this dude on it and this
dude he doesn't look like he's doing too
good
as is what we're gonna say he looks he's
really really skinny
like he shouldn't even be walking around
he should probably be dead skinny like
like monstrously skinny
and he just keeps coming up and saying
that he wants food that he's just like
he's so
so hungry and it's like even the um the
first part of the book i think is called
the hungry man
and so this dude just shows up and
obviously he's very very ill but they
don't really know what's the matter with
him
and it also appears too that he's been
eating some stuff
that is not food in his quest
to fill this hunger that is apparently
overtaking him so this guy
so tim sees this guy and he's basically
like flipping it he's like okay well
i'll give you something to eat but you
can't really hang out here because you
know there's these kids and
you know i'm supposed to be watching
them and i don't know what
is wrong with you and all this other
stuff so what ends up happening
is that this guy starts kind of
acting crazy like i said he's like
eating [ __ ] that's not food like he'll
basically eat anything that's not nailed
down um
you know rocks whatever like grass so he
ends up
i can't remember if he like pukes over
tim or barf
or something like that it happens that
after this dude dies
because i mean it's very clear from the
beginning that he's gonna die because he
just looks like
[ __ ] a zombie walking around and what
they discover
is that his entire body is
essentially filled with tapeworms
and these tapeworms which you find out
over the course of the story like from
the uh you know the newspaper articles
and things like that
they're not regular tapeworms they are
basically a genetically engineered
tapeworm
i'll get into that a little bit so this
guy is full of like there's like one
really big tapeworm
that they kind of pull out because tim
has the weird idea
and i think the implication i don't
think that they i don't um
know if he says this outright i got the
impression that once the tapeworms took
you over
not only did they just make you want to
eat everything like they and you can't
get any nutrients which is why like some
people are like losing like 30 pounds
like in a day or two
because it just eats everything inside
you and it also just keep
makes you keep eating and it doesn't
care if it's food or not it's just kind
of what it just
you know it makes you super super hungry
so you just like kind of you know eat
start eating your own [ __ ] fingers
and like
you know drywall or whatever so it does
that but it also
seems to and it seems to affect the
different
kids in a different ways like when they
get it but
tim who is the first one aside from this
random stranger to get it he starts to
get the idea
like when the guy comes in there and
after he dies
he basically gets one of the kids hey
come in here and help me because uh tim
is a doctor too if i didn't mention that
he's like the town doctor
and he's like we need to cut this dude
open and like see what's going like they
need to do come
some kind of surgery on him and he
somehow has the bright idea to like like
let one of the kids help out and i'm
just like wow that really sounds like a
dumb idea but then like you can hear
his internal monologue which is really
kind of a dialogue because you know
one side of him which i guess is still
the rational side and it's sit there
going what the [ __ ] am i doing this is
the stupidest idea ever we should like
just quarantine this dude and
not touch him but then he has this other
this other part of his mind that's being
like yeah get that kid in here and let's
cut this guy open so i guess that's
they're implying that the parasite also
controls the way you think because later
on
when some of the kids get the parasites
later
they start thinking that even though
they you know they've lost like 30
pounds and they're just like ravaged by
worms and they're just eating rocks and
whatever they think that they're
they have superpowers even though
they're shambling around like
you know and they're clearly dying it
makes but they think they're super
strong and super powerful and everything
so i think that the parasite also has um
has that aspect to it where
it will make you think whatever you need
to think to propagate it
like to spread it to somebody else so
tim ends up getting
the worms and so he realizes pretty
quickly oh [ __ ] this is not good
and it's gonna spread everywhere because
what ends up happening is that there's
like one big tapeworm and then there's a
whole bunch of like
little little tiny ones that can
basically get in anywhere like at one
point not to be gross
but at one point the parasites like
basically crawl
up one of the kids pee holes you know
so that's how small they are but there's
just like one big one and it
just keeps like reproducing like inside
the bodies or whatever like
like a real tapeworm but like i said
these are there's more to these
tapeworms than that
so tim realizes because he's like oh
[ __ ] i got
this dude like he had got his juices on
me and now
i have the worms and so he figures out
pretty quick look
you guys you kids need to get away from
me and so so they'd lock him in a closet
in a cabin and then there's all this
other [ __ ] happens like there's a big
storm and like a tree falls on the cabin
it's like so tim gets killed
so now these five kids are on this
island
all by themselves with a bunch of
tapeworms like you know that are
spreading
to everybody so at this point
it kind of goes into i don't want to say
it's too much like lord of the flies
because i think a lot of people have
kind of
oversold that a little bit it's only
like lord of the flies in the sense that
here's a bunch of little boys who are
left on an island with no adult
supervision and then there's like a
really really bad situation brewing
and they kind of have to figure out how
to survive and
the presence of shelley one of the kids
who
is a straight-up psychopath in a sense
like starts working against the other
kids because
his whole motivation is hooray i now
have
complete license to do all these
horrible things that i've always wanted
to do but was never really allowed to
because i would get into too much
trouble
so you so you have that going on too
like as a wild card type of thing
so i mean basically as i said from very
early on early on in the book you know
that only one
of the kids is gonna live um like i said
you don't know which one it is
uh you know pretty quick it's not gonna
be kent because he's kind of the first
one to get the worms
and uh so it basically just goes on from
that like
you know the parasites keep moving from
kid to kid and
uh so their whole thing is like trying
to survive um trying to
get off the island because the dude the
hungry man that came
in the beginning he had a boat but
he ate the spark plugs because like i
said
they're eating everything so they find
out later like
one of the kids remembers i think it's
max remembers later hey when
me and uh you know scoutmaster tim were
rooting around in this dude's stomach
i saw something shiny in there maybe
it's the spark plugs so they have to go
in there and like reach around inside
this dude's like gross ass guts
and like find the spark plug and then
shelly steals them and it's like this
whole thing
so again you so that's kind of the main
narrative and then you have
sort of all these newspaper articles and
all these kind of um
all these kind of uh you know testimony
uh you know of people that
it was like a trial afterward now it
turns out what these tape worms are
is that there was a a scientific
lab or whatever and there's this one guy
i can't remember the name of the the of
the doctor
but he's kind of like this crazy doctor
like genius dr frankenstein type [ __ ]
and he apparently had two different
contracts going where they were trying
to
modify this tapeworm
and one company that was paying him was
like hey we want a tapeworm
that people can eat like in a pill and
it'll make them lose all this weight
like really quick
but this tapeworm was supposed to only
be in your body for
like the few days it would take you to
lose as much as you wanted to lose and
then it was supposed to die and was
supposed to be passed out of your system
so he's working on that uh but also
unbeknownst to
many other people he also had a military
contract
to make something essentially a
biological weapon
so he was working on both those things
and he succeeded in [ __ ] spades
probably better than he was expecting
so what ended up happening was that the
dude from the beginning who was the guy
that first came to fall staff island on
the boat the hungry man
he was one of their lab rats their
experiments
apparently they had paid he was like
some dude who was like down on his luck
and they were saying
hey you know we're doing all these
medical experimentation for money and
they didn't really tell him what it was
so they essentially infected him with
this tapeworm and then he escaped
and everything just like everything
became a huge [ __ ]
so what else is going on too while these
kids are on this island
the military and everything like that
finds out about it pretty fast because
they knew that that dude had escaped
from the lab and they're like holy [ __ ]
we need to contain this situation
so basically these kids have been left
on this island
and the military is like surrounded
because you know not too far into the
story
like after tim dies and everything the
kids start to notice
all these boats like out on the thing
and like helicopters and stuff
so for a time they're kind of thinking
oh well the adults will come
fix it they'll save us like our parents
will come save us or anything like that
but what they don't realize
until much later in the story is that
this was
you know it wasn't meant to escape but
it was a bioengineered
parasite um that got out and so they're
trying to contain the situation
and they are perfectly happy to let
these kids die on this island
to make sure that this parasite doesn't
get off and starts spreading because
it's very very
virulent and it's very very and it
spreads really really quickly
so these kids are essentially just being
sacrificed and some of the people like
some of the um
you know uh the testimony of the people
later we're just kind of like you know
oops we weren't happy about it but what
the [ __ ] are you gonna do it's like
you know yes it's sad that like the five
kids were there and we just kind of
[ __ ] left them and they
wouldn't let their parents come get them
or anything like that but
you know if it got out if it got off of
that island then we're all [ __ ] it
would have like spread
and you know millions of people would
have died so that's kind of how they
uh talked about it so um so that's kind
of how this
uh how the story goes i don't know you
know it's like i said i'm not gonna
spoil it too much but
you know one kid does live doesn't
really have an easy time of it obviously
because
like some really really bad [ __ ]
happened but like i said i mean this is
a pretty gross ass book if you were not
down
with reading about tapeworms or reading
about
um you know various bodily fluids and
people reaching around inside other
people's guts people eating disgusting
things
this is really not the book for you
because it's pretty nasty
also like i said there's a lot a lot
of um pretty graphically described
animal cruelty
um there is uh there's one part where
they're talking about when they were
first doing the experimentation on the
worms
and they basically um put the worms
inside
i think it was a chimpanzee so you kind
of like have the person that was
watching
the test kind of talking about what's
happening with the chimpanzee and that
was really upsetting the character of
shelley who like i said as a psychopath
there's a lot of [ __ ] of him doing
horrible stuff to animals including um
you know pinching the eyes off a crab
and like just pulling a crab apart just
for fun
uh there's a flashback scene of him
drowning a kitten
uh in a bathtub and then setting it on
fire so
and uh probably the worst and i mean
that was the most upsetting for me
because obviously i'm a cat person
there was also one really horrifying
scene which
was um i think it was max and newt and
they were stuck on this island with no
food obviously because everybody that
got the parasite got super hungry so
somebody ate
all of their food i think it was kent
and he so he ate all the food that they
had brought for the trip
and they didn't have anything else and
they couldn't get off the island
obviously to get anything else
so they're kind of like eating berries
and [ __ ] like that in the woods
so at one point they find like a sea
turtle
like trapped in a little tide pool and
they decide well we have to kill it and
eat it and they don't really want to
and there's this real and it's a really
prolonged
horrifying i mean it's it's necessary to
the scene and because they feel horrible
about it and but
just the way it's described is just like
really really horrific
it kind of reminded me of that scene
from cannibal holocaust you know like
with the sea turtle
where they killed it for real it kind of
reminded me of that a little bit
but just the way it's described in the
way that the boys feel about it
it's just like really really it's it's
just really horrifying and
heart-wrenching
so uh so yeah if that's gonna bother you
too there's a lot of that in there
um i'm not i don't think it's excessive
i don't think it's unnecessary i don't
think it's in there just to be shocking
but you know i'm just saying it's like
if you're not really down with reading
[ __ ] like that because i did see some
reviews on goodreads that as soon as
they got to like some of the scenes they
were just like nope i'm out you know so
just a warning that's all i'm saying but
yeah other than that if you really like
body horror if you really like really
gory stuff really gross [ __ ]
um you will probably really dig this i
had a great time with this book i think
it's really really it's
awesomely written it's really
entertaining all of the kids
i think it took me a little while for to
for me to differentiate all the kids
from one another because i'm sitting
there going
wait which kid is that but then as it
went on and you got
each of their internal monologues you
know it they became a lot more distinct
um i will say that probably newt was my
favorite character although max was
pretty awesome too
so when bad [ __ ] happened to them later
on in the book you were really kind of
bummed out about it because they they
really seemed like
real kids like they really kind of came
off the page and the way that they
interacted with each other kind of
reminded me of
um stand by me or the body uh you know
the original story by stephen king
it kind of reminded me of that with just
like these boys and they're out in the
woods and just like the way they talk to
each other
and stuff like that and they you know
just trying to
you know keep their loyalty keep their
friendship together and
you know as the horrors just kept
escalating
and the fact that some of them were able
to keep their [ __ ] together enough
to you know at least try to escape at
least try to do something about what was
happening to them
was really really it was just really
compelling and also really heartbreaking
because you kind of know from the
beginning that most of them
are not going to make it and you know
even if they do make it
it's like just you can't imagine i can't
imagine like going through something
like this it would just be
all the [ __ ] that they had to see and
all the [ __ ] that they had to do and
stuff was just like [ __ ] horrifying
so yeah but so i can totally see
all of the hype for this book it's just
it's just very well written
the characters are very well-rounded um
it's just it's gross it's squeaky it's
um
you know it's kind of creepy like skin
crawling like not scary scary but
just in that just kind of grows the
music you know kind of way it's kind of
like that
but yeah i mean i would totally
recommend it um i feel like if they made
a movie of this it would probably make
me
want to gag but um it would probably
also be really good
i've seen this actually called lord of
the flies meets the ruins
which i also reviewed the ruins a little
while back if you want to go watch that
which like i said that's kind of
accurate
in the body horror sense because you
know the ruins was actually kind of
about a vine that sort of took over your
body and this is like worms to take over
your body
so it's you know it's kind of a similar
thing like i said i think the lord of
the flies thing is slightly overplayed
because i don't think it's that much
like lord of the flies except for
the dynamic between shelley and the
other four boys him just being a
psychopath like
happy that he can run amok on this
island and do all these horrible things
um so i think that's where the lord of
the flies thing comes from but yeah it
was
it was just a totally fun gross read
it's almost kind of like
i got kind of a throwback sort of vibe
to it like just kind of that just real
gory like 80s horror kind of but a
little bit elevated like i feel like the
literary
i guess because uh nick cutter you know
in his craig davidson
uh name under under his real name uh
he's actually a literary fiction writer
and he's actually won a lot of awards
and stuff
and you can really see that in the way
that stuff is written like some of the
um some of the language like some of the
metaphorical
language some of the way he describes
things are really really um
evocative and really kind of make you
see it like in your mind's eye so
so yeah i mean this was solidly for four
and a half star
uh read for me i just really had a good
time with it so if you like throwback
80s horror if you like really gross [ __ ]
then uh pick it up if you haven't read
it i know a lot of people have
and i'm kind of late to the party but uh
yeah definitely definitely a really good
one
so check it out if you haven't already
and i'll see you on the next one
bye